I remember going across the channel I
looked on my right side and there was a
destroyer very close to us
as if it was yesterday it comes back
usually the wet or boiling hot in
Normandy 76 years on d-day veterans
faced a new challenge coronavirus has
stopped them gathering despite a small
service on the beaches of Normandy it
was a stark contrast to last year but
those who fought are still doing their
bit at 96 and 95 veterans Len Gibbon and
Peter Hawkins are on their bikes
they've pedaled a hundred and four miles
to raise money for their care home the
same distance as their crossing to
Normandy in 1944 if we can help them as
much as they help us anytime
I've got no objections it's just I had
to give it some thought because as you
say 104 miles there's quite a distance
using my energy in some way while the
virus has stopped as gathering services
were still held the British Legion
streamed theirs on Facebook from the
d-day memorial stone in Portsmouth I
think it's important to find ways of
enabling as many people as possible to
continue to engage and particularly at
this time to remember and reflect on the
importance of the freedoms we have and
held those who gave their lives
encouraged us to think about how we live
our lives today for peace and justice so
really important to get as many people
engaged with that way of thinking and to
access that opportunity to reflect
through as many different media as
possible while events have adapted those
who've served say nothing compares to
meeting face to face you can't beat the
real thing you can't beat being
somewhere
feeling it seeing it smelling it that's
that's special that's that's reality the
virtual world is okay up to a point but
the real world well I think we all want
to be able to get back to however we
remember veterans say it's vital you do
o matic one for service it's just to
bring back memories and pay respect to
those that didn't come back because
we're all in the same boat
dan white hits Sky News in Portsmouth